salut ouais
je veux juste vérifier deux trois trucs
ça le fait ou pas il marche pas celui-là
non il marche pas
non c'est pas possible il y a le numéro
de série c'est le mien
alors elle est là la Brenda que j'adore
tu t'es fait voler ton vélo écouter ma
petite histoire c'était en janvier
dernier qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il
s'est passé qu'un matin je pars pour
emmener ma petite fille à l'école mais
vous avez 12 ans j'ai 27 ans bientôt
ouais et un matin j'ouvre la porte du
locabelo je vois plus de vélo je
commence à devenir dingos
je fais comment moi pour emmener ma
petite à l'école et du coup bah après
bah je suis parti à pied j'ai pris une
journée de travail je suis allé au
commissariat j'ai porté plainte comme
tout le monde quoi voilà et la dame de
la commissaire elle m'a dit oubliez
votre vélo vous le retrouverez jamais
et du coup j'ai fini par le retrouver
sur leboncoin un bon matin tous les
jours je regardais les annonces tous les
jours tous les matins je regardais les
annonces et un matin je vois la petite
annonce avec ton vélo avec mon vélo
parce qu'en fait moi j'ai eu un accident
avec ce vélo là j'ai eu un grave
accident quand même et du coup il est
tout rayé sur un côté le j'ai mis un
rétro j'ai mis un porte téléphone donc
il est quand même
et donc donc tu le retrouves donc tu le
retrouves donc qu'est-ce que tu fais et
donc qu'est-ce que je fais donc j'ai
préparé mon coup j'ai appelé j'ai été au
commissariat où j'ai porté plainte je
suis arrivé en furie j'ai dit que bah
j'avais retrouvé mon vélo sur leboncoin
et tout il fallait qu'il me prépare une
équipe donc ils m'ont préparé mes petits
et j'ai dit j'ai donné rendez-vous à 16h
au mec et du coup je suis arrivée direct
j'ai dit je vais aller chercher mon vélo
sinon je vais y aller j'ai retrouvé mon
vélo on y va direct voilà ils t'ont pas
dit ouais mais madame 2 minutes on va
voir c'est vrai ils ont été super ils
sont super les policiers
on y va j'appelle la bague donc commence
à 11h30 donc le temps qu'il se prépare
Nani qui s'équipe et tout ça ils sont
équipés de ouf et tout
non mais il commençait à 11h30 et du
coup le rendez-vous était à 16h donc le
temps de se préparer de droits
et donc arrête ça va et du coup
et donc ouais donc là tu pars avec qui
là
j'étais avec ma meilleure amie Stacy on
y va tout déter tac le mec je lui dis
vas-y sort avec le vélo sans règle je te
rejoins devant les poubelles là que
j'étais devant les poubelles
tac lui il arrivait avec le vélo alors
il tranquille comme ça il arrive
alors le mec il se fait pas chier déjà
il monte sur le vélo
et puis il arrive donc je fais genre de
d'acheter un vélo donc je contrôle les
freins je contrôle tout quoi je regarde
et ma copine juste avant que le mec il
arrive je lui dis appelle-les donc j'ai
le numéro du policier
son 06 et du coup elle l'habitait ils
sont arrivés en furie c'était caché
genre une rue derrière ils sont arrivés
bam ils l'ont attrapé
oui il y a un problème c'est mon vélo
limite vachement bien
et donc c'est incroyable et donc tu as
récupéré le vélo j'ai récupéré le vélo
donc du coup il dort dans ma chambre qui
est le mec
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors le voleur il était mineur voilà il
est mineur donc il a fait 48 heures de
garde à vue et
là le problème alors quand ils l'ont
contrôlé il avait un couteau de 30 cm de
cuisine
et je me suis fait gronder par le
policier en disant mais vous êtes pas
bien non c'est rigoler
la police
ils sont venus avec vous mais à un
moment ils vont venir quoi ils vont dire
il fallait pas faire ça bah il fallait
pas faire ça toute seule j'ai dit mais
déjà j'étais pas toute seule j'étais
avec ma meilleure copine il y en a un
sims
j'ai ma copine non non
j'ai pris
mon courage à deux mains j'y suis allé
c'est pas un gamin de 17 ans qui va me
faire peur en fait
tout le début de l'histoire ma madame
vous êtes formidable c'est-à-dire que
vous retrouvez le vélo etc mais la fin
excusez-moi vous avez pris un risque
délirant moi je suis très en colère
contre vous parce qu'effectivement votre
non mais le voleur il a un couteau il
aurait pu vous donner un coup de couteau
et vous auriez pu être blessé madame
mais c'est justement pour ça que votre
erreur c'est d'avoir voulu jouer le jeu
vous-même à Strasbourg quelqu'un a fait
comme vous mais il a appelé la BAC qui a
joué les acheteurs c'est deux policiers
en civil qui ont joué les acheteurs vous
pouvez pas vous substituer à la police
madame vous avez pris un risque
inconsidéré moi je suis en colère contre
vous parce que je vous aime énormément
et là franchement c'est délirant ce que
vous avez fait on peut pas cautionner ce
risque que vous avez pris alors tout le
monde réagit sur cette histoire de vélo
parce que vous avez passionné tout le
monde évidemment juste parce que la
question que l'on se pose Gilles et je
le comprends ils vous ont pas dit un
moment la police non non on va aller on
va faire genre c'est nous qui allons
acheter le vélo et vous non ils ont
suivi votre plan d'ailleurs vous avez
dit bon alors vous quoi je dis moi je
vais y aller moi c'est mon vélo j'ai
insisté un beau vélo
aujourd'hui je voulais récupérer mon
vélo là maintenant tout de suite et
quand je veux un truc et ben j'y vais
c'est tout le problème c'est Michel le
problème c'est que même arrêté il va pas
faire 10 ans de prison pour avoir le
vélo donc il est déjà en liberté bon il
peut très bien avoir envie de se venger
vous dit qu'il y a un couteau même sans
parler du couteau il peut très bien dire
ça elle est malade mapouka mais elle m'a
balancé je vais venir me venger ou dans
la rue même si sans vous de l'histoire
de vous tuer mais au moins vous tapez
rien est-ce que vous avez peur de de
chantage et ben les filles qui sont ils
ont fait le traquenard eux même si ils
ont piéger la terre c'est quelqu'un qui
faisait du chantage à une sextape enfin
sextape une photo intima c'est quoi
l'histoire bah c'était une fille avec
qui j'avais j'avais loué des relations
épistolaire enfin par écrit sur les
réseaux
non j'avais jamais vu parce qu'elle
habitait loin soit disant Orléans devait
se voir qu'un jour plus tard
oui une photo intime c'est-à-dire une
photo sous la douche on fait une photo
ouais les gens voyaient le pommeau
[Applaudissements]
elle avait fait en premier peu importe
et du coup elle me elle voulait me
donner rendez-vous mais au dernier
moment il m'a dit je viendrai en ce
moment je voudrais pas mais il était si
tu veux pas que je balance ma photo à
tout le monde et elle me réclamait 3500
€ comme ça j'ai été porté plainte j'ai
hésité mais est-ce que je peux pas j'ai
été voir les policiers qui ont décidé de
monter à tractar pour la choper mon
dîner pas tout ça et c'est eux qui sont
occupés bon ils n'ont pas chopé parce
que visiblement elle avait des doutes
elle s'est barrée avant d'arriver sur
place mais voilà mais c'est très
dangereux de voir se faire justice
soi-même parce que le franchement lui il
est déjà en liberté quoi
je me suis protégée j'ai acheté un petit
un petit truc quand vous êtes arrivés
tu flippes un peu quand même bah je
flippe c'est pour ça j'ai un taser quand
je vais au boulot je vais mon petit
Taser dans mes poches que si cher qu'un
vélo
surtout qu'il est dans votre quartier je
crois il est assez fier en fait d'avoir
fait le buzz sur les réseaux je n'ai pas
du tout conscient d'avoir fait quelque
chose il le sera pas parce qu'il va
avoir trois jours de didité de je sais
pas comment ça s'appelle rappel à la loi
je pense pas il a déjà plusieurs
condamnations là on est à la 10 11e
condamnation le gamin il est encore
parlé de quatre trottinettes
sur leboncoin
des trottinettes des trucs volés
on va avoir une sœur une sœur mais pas
le
top
oui vraiment moi je trouve ça dommage je
trouve ça très dommage que ce soit à
elle de faire la police d'abord elle va
pas se laisser faire voler son vélo
comme ça et rien faire et en acheter un
autre sous prétexte qui allait après il
y a des représailles bien sûr que c'est
dangereux bien sûr que toutes ces
vermine la 11 condamnation on se
condamnation et ça vole encore des vélos
il y en a marre franchement il y en a
marre donc elle a eu raison tu as eu
raison de faire d'appeler pour récupérer
ton vélo là où je suis pas très content
c'est que la police n'aurait pas dû te
laisser y aller quand t'as dit le temps
qu'il se prépare ils auraient dû venir
tout de suite en voyant ta détermination
ils auraient se dire Madame ne le fait
pas vous on va y aller nous on va il y a
un mec qui va venir faire croire que
c'est l'acheteur et on coffre et on
verra jamais votre tête et on saura
jamais
parler ils ont fait le truc
je vais te dire non mais parce que là
c'est
Paul de vélo tout ça voilà c'est Valérie
tu comprends ce que je veux dire les
gens qui ont besoin de vélo ça coûte
cher les vélos vous êtes fous oh mais là
ils estimé qu'il y avait pas une urgence
absolue il s'agit entre guillemets
pardon madame exactement d'un vélo
exactement
il y avait j'avais aussi la remorque
avait pour ma fille derrière alors déjà
une remorque ça coûte près de 300 euros
aussi
on est déjà 700 €, non mais j'entends
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que moi je vous suis à 200% sur toute
votre histoire y compris lorsque vous
allez voir les policiers en disant
maintenant je veux récupérer mon vélo je
sais j'ai pris rendez-vous avec
l'acheteur et cetera et en revanche là
où je me suis plus du tout c'est quand
vous y allez vous voilà c'est là où je
vous perds je pense que c'était
effectivement comme pour l'histoire de
Jean-Michel eux qui endossent le rôle de
la je sais pas et qui prennent pas de
risque va revolver votre vélo
bah non il dort dans ma chambre le vélo
quoi maintenant vous mettez vraiment le
vélo dans votre chambre
je préfère mon vélo à mon mari
alors comme ça d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi je trouve que quand les citoyens
engagés s'unissent avec la police pour
le bien et contre l'injustice je trouve
ça formidable pour moi vous êtes
vraiment un exemple de courage
j'aimerais être comme vous et moi
lorsque les citoyens
se substitue non mais c'est incroyable
pour moi c'est une héroïne
elle a pris un risque mais c'est la
classe aujourd'hui
les citoyens s'unissent souhaitent la
police non mais vous vous avez vu ça où
non mais moi dans la France que je veux
je veux que les que les que les
personnes qui veulent le bien les
citoyens engagés les bonnes personnes et
les travailleurs et ceux qui respectent
la loi s'unissent avec la police et pas
vous voulez créer des milices
existe déjà dans les zones
résidentielles par exemple dans le Sud
où il y a beaucoup de maisons que c'est
inoccupé on demande à tous les habitants
de surveiller les voisins les autres
habitations et d'appeler la police ils
voient des normales ça existe déjà vous
avez un rôle de passif vous n'êtes pas
actif comme madame qui a pris un risque
inconsciente mais on veut pas savoir
merci c'est bon mais ce qui est terrible
c'est que maintenant c'est vous qui avez
peur en fait c'est-à-dire vous avez
quand même un taser chez vous vous avez
vous dormez avec votre vélo chez vous
enfin je veux dire c'est vous qui est
dans une situation qui est complètement
US c'est ça qui me qui moi qui me
trouble voyez ce que je veux dire bah
après je dors avec mon vélo parce que
d'une ils ont pas réparé la porte il a
pété toute la porte ils ont ils ont tout
cassé mais là c'est mineur il a des
parents ou pas alors je crois que c'est
pas trop je crois que c'est fait
juste son père mais son père il en peut
plus donc du coup moi j'ai contacté le
maire de la ville qui a été génial et
qui
et qui a justement fait des signalements
au procureur à la magistrat pour que ce
il soit enfermé on en peut plus dans le
quartier c'est sûr
tu la recroisé depuis non maintenant il
sort plus là depuis ah ouais je l'ai pas
revu et tu as pas peur de le recroiser
là non vraiment il y a tellement tout le
village il est avec moi donc
[Applaudissements]
le maire a été voir son père lui a dit
vous faites vous il abandonne le père il
en peut plus son gamin
il travaille pas il va pas à l'école
c'est un cassos
il a 17 ans
le mineur Daniel la majeur est majeur là
cette année-là cette année d'accord donc
là il a arrêté les cours il est toute la
journée
s'est fait virer de l'école et tout mais
il fait que
tu as essayé de lui parler ou pas du
tout
je parle pas avec ces gens là il
caillasse les vieux dans le quartier ah
ouais ouais il est en liberté du coup il
est en liberté personne ne lui dit rien
30 cm
je dis un mot enfin il me semble qu'il y
a un truc qui s'appelle comparution
immédiate est-ce que pour ce jeune homme
ça serait pas bien et qu'il fasse un peu
vraiment de la prison pour voir ce que
c'est pour qu'il réfléchisse un peu
il faut peut-être l'aider mais l'aider à
ne pas justement à ce qui ne lis plus à
la société on va pas lui voilà
un peu de temps pour servir au moins les
gens alors il y a beaucoup de gens aussi
parce qu'on va voir la vidéo voilà il y
a beaucoup de gens qui arrivent sur TPMP
voilà de cette histoire de vélo c'est
vrai que regarder et c'est vrai que sur
nous on a flouté son visage mais sur les
réseaux on voit son visage il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont peur qu'il y
ait des représailles voilà pour cette
vidéo c'est pas moi qui l'ai publié déjà
la vidéo elle a été elle a fuité je l'ai
envoyé si vous voulez à une maman de
l'école qui l'envoyait à sa sœur qui l'a
envoyé au petit les petits l'ont renvoyé
il y en a un qui l'a publié et lala et
voilà c'est parti comme ça et elle a été
publiée au moins 40 fois sur TikTok
c'est c'est n'importe quoi c'est je
pensais pas que ça allait prendre une
ampleur aussi vous dites aux gens qui
disent ouais ils peuvent avoir des
représailles il peut avoir il peut être
en danger à cause de cette vidéo
parce que c'est un menteur fini il fait
que mentir il a dit déjà qu'il arrivait
il poussait le vélo quand il me l'a
apporté alors déjà il monte dessus sur
le vélo il ment il ment il ment comme il
respire c'est un mythomane c'est un je
sais pas comment on dit là ceux qui
veulent tout le temps les vélos là mais
merci
demandent aussi de filmer parce que ça
servira pour la procédure c'est à dire
qu'il y aura une autre authentification
et il sera poursuivi possiblement pour
Russell de vol vol je sais pas parce
qu'il faudrait prouver que soit lui qui
ait le vélo voilà il dira peut-être que
non mais recel de vol oui et risque de
la prison après Cyril la question c'est
un mineur comme ça qui empoisonne tout
un quartier effectivement c'est
invivable pour les gens vous vous allez
dire qu'il soit enfermé peut-être je
suis désolé pour un mineur comme ça la
prison ne va rien régler alors on va le
condamner peut-être à la prison mais ça
ne sert à rien il faut des mesurer
éducatives dans des centres spécialisés
parce que la prison s'il fait un mois de
prison il sortira et ce sera pire donc
moi je suis contre la prison dans ce
cas-là pour les mineurs et donc là je
sais c'est
qu'elle aurait pu faire attendre que la
procédure mais là il y aura une
procédure à mon avis il est identifié il
y aura une procédure mais effectivement
je ne pense pas qu'il sera condamné à la
maison c'est que aucune sanction ça ne
va régler non plus ça fait le mec il est
content c'est en lui envoie le signal
que c'est pas grave du tout de voler un
vélo et en plus c'est devenu une star de
Tik Tok je suis sûr qu'il en est fier de
la vidéo c'est le monde
veut dire que de sortir de prison ça
sera pire tous les délinquants sont
libertés
non on se condamnation quand même c'est
à dire qu'en fait quelque part tu
protèges plus ce garçon-là que
mademoiselle qui est victime en fait ça
dans ta société à toi c'est quand même
compliqué
aux H&M parce que moi j'habite dans un
HLM il a tout démonté il a démonté les
portes les bâtiments ils sont neufs j'ai
emménage au mois d'avril ils sont 9 les
bâtiments il a déjà tout éclaté le mec
voilà ensuite il y a des grosses caméras
360 aux portes il est il sait même pas
caché il croit que les caméras elle
marche pas
la seule il y a au moins trois quatre
cinq plaintes il y a tous les voisins
alors aujourd'hui donc il habite à 700
mètres de chez vous
vous allez certainement le recroiser un
jour vous allez faire quand vous allez
recroiser
du prêter mon vélo
c'est le meilleur moyen parce que si je
vais lui parler il va dire ah on a
provoqué c'est pas le but le but c'est
on passe au tribunal le 23 enfin tu
passes au tribunal et voilà terminé je
prends ce que tu as à prendre et moi le
juge peut décider de mesures
d'éloignement c'est-à-dire qu'il est
plus le droit de venir dans un périmètre
autour de là où est vélo Moselle bah du
vélo et de Mademoiselle
donc au final cette vidéo affûté quels
sont les retours que vous avez reçus des
gens justement bah bravo Madame
j'ai lu quelques commentaires parce que
ça m'avait saoulé je suis pas très
réseau moi à la base
voilà je vais j'en ai marre qu'il fasse
des des trucs de fou je veux lui donner
une leçon c'est ça ben non même pas je
pensais pas que ça allaiter à la base je
voulais garder la vidéo pour moi et les
policiers et l'envoyer à ma famille mes
amis sauf qu'elle a futé et puis voilà
tu es content qu'elle
il va prendre plus cher que tu fais tu
travailles oui ils t'ont dit quoi les
gens au taf
bravo parce que déjà je travaille dans
mon quartier je fais des pizzas dans le
quartier d'accord et il se met tout le
temps devant là où je travaille
Ikea des gens ils filment les policiers
comme ça quand ils passent on les
traitant de
enfin il les insultent enfin je lui ai
même fait sauter son compte Tik Tok
parce qu'il se filme avec le maire film
avec les policiers on les insultant moi
je cautionne pas ça c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible
qui connaît bien tout ce milieu quand
une personne comme ça récidive
le milieu
carcéral pourquoi est-ce qu'un jeune
comme ça qui a tellement de de problèmes
n'est pas n'est pas mis hors état de
nuire en fait parce qu'en France on
emprise pas les mineurs et je sais que
ça déplaise c'est une en France c'est
l'exception d'emprisonner un mineur avec
ça tu es d'accord avec ça c'est
l'exception j'ai dit Jean-Michel en
France la règle c'est de ne pas
emprisonner des mineurs voilà 17 ans on
peut l'être mais c'est très rare merci
en tout cas d'avoir été avec nous
est-ce que est-ce qu'on a un sondage
s'il vous plaît oui tu as eu raison 92%
oui